نعم هناك استمرار في عمليه الانجلاء كما
ذكرت لك على مدار الساعه يعني الساعه
الماضيه يعني يبدو ان الوضع كان هادئ ربما
في انتظار وصول وفود جديده للخروج من
بوابه هذا المعبر بعد انتهاء الاجراءات
يعني كنا قد تحدثنا مع بعض الذين قد خرجوا
خلال الساعات الماضيه والذين تحدثوا بانها
كانت رحله طويله وشاقه وانهم يعني يشعرون
اخيرا بالامان بعد الوصول الى المعبر
المصري ربما في انتظارهم رحله طويله ايضا
للوصول الى مدينه اسوان التي تبعد حوالي
اكثر من 400 كيلو متر يعني حوالي خمس
ساعات بالحافلات والسيارات هذه الحافلات
التي تنتظر ربما خروج هذه الوفود حتى الان
يعني لا يوجد اي ارقام دقيقه او احصائيات
دقيقه لان الارقام تتغير على مدار الساعه
ولكن مع مساء كل يوم يكون هناك بيان مفصل
من وزاره الخارجيه المصريه حول اجمالي ما
تم اجلائهم من مصريين او من سودانيين من
من المنافذ المصريه او حتى من خلال
الطائرات المصريه العسكريه التي تذهب الى
الخرطوم بشكل يومي لنقل الكثير من
العالقين المصريين يعني هناك بالفعل عمل
لربما يعتبره البعض على قدم وساق لمساله
انهاء وتسهيل خروج
المصريين والسوريين وايضا الرعايه الدول
الاجنبيه فجر اليوم التقيد بسفير جورجيا
الذي جاء بنفسه للاشراف على عمليه
الاجلاء كان هناك ايضا ممثلين من الملحق
العسكري من اوكرانيا ايضا من دول اخرى مثل
ايطاليا خلال الايام الماضيه كل هذه
الامور يتم العمل فيها وايضا يتم التنسيق
مع الجانب السوداني لتوفير ممرات امنه
للوصول من يريد ان يصل الى الحدود المصريه
من خلال الحافلات ومن ثم سيكون هناك ايضا
كما ذكرت لك رحله اخرى الى مدينه اسوان
اغلب من التقيتهم من سودانيين اكدوا انهم
سينكسون لا لفتره هناك الكثير من الاصدقاء
والاهالي والاقارب في اسوان هناك اقتراب
في العادات ربما ايضا هناك ايجار البيوت
خلال المرحله المقبله سيكون ارخص كثيرا من
التوجه الى القاهره بعض المصريين والاجانب
سيتوجهون الى المطار حيث ان هناك كثافه
كبيره جدا في حجز الطائرات والحافلات
والقطرات التي تتوجه من اسوان الى القاهره
خلال الايام الماضيه ومن المتوقع ان تستمر
هذه الكثافه خلال ايضا الايام المقبله حتى
تتضح الصوره بعد ما التقيتهم سالتهم حول
خطواتهم المقبله اكدوا انهم سينتظرون
لمراقبه المشهد لا احد يستطيع ان ياخذ
قرارا بالعوده مره اخرى او خلال ايام
مقبله الا حينما يكون هناك تاكد من فعلا
هناك التزام بوقف اطلاق النار وبان هناك
هدنه وبان هناك تطور في المشهد السياسي
يسمح لهم بخوض هذه الرحله التي اعتبروها
من اكثر الرحلات التي خاضوا فيها ربما
يعني رعبا خلال
السنوات الماضيه لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات